64 members of congress in the last two  years have violated the stock act  almost 200 of their staffers have also  violated the stock act  and of course these individuals have  information  they've got budget information they know  where money is going to be spent before  it gets spent  and  they can use this information  to buy stocks they can use it to sell  stocks  and a majority of americans 70 percent  of them to be exact  say they want a ban on congressional  stock trading  50 percent of republicans and 45 percent  of democrats say they're actually going  to be more likely to vote for a  candidate if they support a ban on  politicians trading stocks